penn state university today is expected
to discuss significant changes to its
Greek system the school has been
overhauling rules for Greek life after
the alleged hazing death of Timothy
Piazza the 19 year old died in February
after a fall a grand jury presentment
said it happened during a fraternity
hazing ritual involving heavy drinking
eighteen students are charged in
connection with his death
Jericka Duncan is in State College
Pennsylvania with what piazzas family
wants to see happen Jericho good morning
good morning the Beta Theta Pi chapter
here at Penn State has been banned and
some new restrictions have been put in
place on Greek life for example there
can only be ten social events per
semester with alcohol before it was
forty five and today's school leaders
plan to discuss even more ways to
prevent anything like what happened back
in February from happening again Penn
State has a lot of work to do in a
recent interview with CBS News the
parents of Timothy Piazza said banning
the Beta Theta Pi fraternity was only
the start and called on Penn State to
fix what they say is a broken Greek
system I'm not necessarily opposed to
Greek life but it's broken at Penn State
it's broken throughout the country
that's one of the largest institutions
in the country if they speak people will
listen the school told CBS News a
comprehensive set of recommendations to
ensure significant change will be
discussed at today's meeting in a letter
sent to the University Wednesday night
the Piazza family asked the school to
consider a list of suggested changes
that include passing hazing legislation
banning alcohol distribution to underage
students at fraternities or rush events
spot-checking and mandatory safety
classes Piazza died following an alleged
hazing ritual in February according to a
grand jury presentment Beta Theta Pi
pledges were forced to consume heavy
amounts of alcohol in a short amount of
time
it said the Penn State sophomores death
was the direct result of encouraged
reckless conduct that demonstrated a
reckless disregard for human life
last week president and CEO of the North
American
fraternity conference Jud horace spoke
to CBS this morning why is there still
this level of drinking allowed its
fraternities here's the reality of what
we face on college campuses
you have the drinking law and then you
have the reality of the students and we
are caught in a very challenging
position to ensure safety have honest
dialogue about where they are enforced
policies is it helpful for you to be
able to speak about your son yeah I
think it helps us first of all it keeps
them a little bit alive and we know
we're doing something good for him and
that's all we have at this point right
but I think we're doing something good
for a lot of other people's children as
well the Piazza family says they also
want all students culpable in their
son's death to be expelled and they're
asking the university to fire any staff
who knew about issues within the Greek
system a source tells CBS News that the
legal counsel for Beta Theta Pi is
planning to sue Penn State University to
get reinstated here on campus Gail all
right areca thank you